alors Pierre Palmade a été déféré devant
le juge d'instruction à midi l'ont amené
au tribunal de Melun là-dessus le
procureur à Rocky la détention
provisoire et également l'état de
récidive légale puisque il a été déjà
condamné était condamné pour possession
et usage de stupéfiant là-dessus le
l'avocat de Pierre Palmade la défendue
la puce expliquer il a reconnu qu'il
avait effectivement fait la fête pendant
24 heures avec des amis et qu'il y avait
eu consommation de drogue et de drogue
de substitution là-dessus le juge
d'instruction la mis en examen pour
homicide involontaire et blessures à
volontaires ayant entraîné un arrêt de
travail de plus de trois mois à 16h30 il
a été placé devant le juge des libertés
des détentions et là-dessus on lui a
donc signifié qu'il serait sous un sous
contrôle judiciaire strict avec
obligation de porter un bracelet
électronique et qu'il serait assigné à
résidence dans un service d'addictologie
à l'hôpital Paul Brousse à Villejuif non
est-ce que les deux personnes qui
étaient avec une voiture était également
au tribunal aujourd'hui oui elles
étaient également tribunal aujourd'hui
alors elle elles ont été placées sous le
statut de témoin assisté parce que elles
ont fait valoir que elles avaient pris
la fuite une fois que l'été les les
secours étaient arrivés sur place et
donc le juge a estimé qu'il n'y avait
pas encore assez d'éléments pour les
mettre pour leur faire une mise en
examen d'accord
aujourd'hui il va mieux il peut
te cassés mais
rien de grave et du coup il va devoir
subir ce qu'il a pu retrouver un peu la
mémoire raconter au passé ou pas au
niveau de l'accident il reste sur ses
positions en disant qu'il y a un
véritable trou noir entre le moment où
il met la serrure dans son dans le
portail de son corps de ferme et le
moment où il se retrouve à l'hôpital
c'est ce qu'il a dit également au juge
d'instruction de rencontrer deux juges
aujourd'hui oui le juste instruction et
le juste des libertés et des et de la
rétention est-ce qu'il a accès il avait
accès à la télévision est-ce qu'il voit
ça à rien du tout pendant toute sa garde
à vue il était dans dans une chambre
d'hôpital dans l'hôpital de Melun il
avait accès à rien il avait juste son
avocate qui pouvait lui rendre visite
d'accord Georges fenêtre avec nous donc
ancien magistrat qui avait porté une loi
sur les responsabilités pénales ils ont
retenu la récidive pour la drogue est-ce
que ça ça aggrave le cas ça dans un pas
forcément sûr ah oui c'est agréable le
cas ça aggrave aussi les pénalités qu'il
en cours d'accord est-ce que la
procédure c'est c'est emballé j'ai envie
de dire compte tenu de longue la
médiatisation de cette affaire ben il
faut quand même savoir que plus de 20%
des accidents mortels sont dus à des
conduites sous l'emprise de produits
stupéfiants il y a à peu près 700 morts
par an
de ce fait là donc évidemment cette
affaire prend une dimension
médiatique parce qu'il s'agit de Pierre
Palmade et puis parce que aussi les
conséquences sont tragiques notamment la
perte d'un bébé mais c'est
malheureusement je dirais presque du
quotidien ces accidents sous l'emprise
d'alcool sous l'emprise de produits
stupéfiants et on comprend parfaitement
qu'on s'intéresse tous à cette affaire
parce qu'il s'agit évidemment de Pierre
Palmade alors justement il y a plein de
gens qui disaient j'ai je crois que
c'est ta question qui George très
franchement on comprend pas le nouveau
procureur de Melun lui il parle de
récidive donc c'est un peu doublé la
sanction tout le monde pensait qu'à ce
moment-là comme le voulait le parquet
Pierre Palmade serait placé en détention
c'est quand même extrêmement étonnant
moi je vous pose la question assez
brutalement est-ce que c'est parce que
c'est Pierre Palmade et qu'il est connu
qu'il a bénéficié de cette clémence
parce que pour moi c'est une immense
Clémence qu'il ne soit pas placé en
détention ce soir absolument pas
absolument pas absolument pas la
détention provisoire ce n'est pas une
sanction et ça n'est pas une présomption
c'est une mesure technique le juge
décide d'une détention provisoire s'il y
a nécessité c'est-à-dire risque de fuite
c'est pas le cas risque de récidive
quasiment nul puisque on retire son
permis dans un hôpital risque de
concertation frauduleuse avec les autres
protagonistes ce sont déjà expliqués
donc il n'y avait pas de raison
technique de le mettre en détention
provisoire mais attention la mesure qui
a été prise elle est quand même très
restrictive de liberté il s'agit d'une
assignation à résidence c'est
l'équivalent d'une détention à domicile
si vous voulez avec un bracelet
électronique donc il ne peut pas sortir
d'un certain périmètre il a des
obligations très contraignantes de soins
donc je ne crois pas qu'on puisse dire
qu'il s'agit d'une mesure de faveur loin
de là c'est important de le dire
attention attention viendra le jour du
procès et là le jour du le procès c'est
plus la même chose là c'est la gravité
de son comportement et des conséquences
qui détermineront la peine et il est en
cours de la prison ferme alors pour
noter les spectateurs
un procès comme ça sur une affaire comme
ça deux ans je pense qu'il y aura au
moins pour un an d'instruction d'accord
il faut faire les expertises les
voitures il faut les expertiser est-ce
qu'il y a pas eu à une défaillance de la
direction du véhicule n'en sais rien on
le sait pas aujourd'hui quels sont les
causes est-ce que c'est l'emprise
effectivement des produits stupéfiants
il y a fortes chances que ce soit ça
bien sûr mais il faut le déterminer que
le déterminer donc tout ça va prendre du
temps il va falloir expertiser les
victimes les préjudices les incapacités
voire même les invalidités tout cela
prendra du temps au minimum un an
ensuite il y a les délais d'audiencement
donc cette affaire ne viendra pas en
jugement avant deux ans je dirais Myriam
Palomba aujourd'hui il va être seul chez
lui non pour l'instant il est placé dans
un service addict à l'hôpital à
l'hôpital de Villejuif donc pour combien
de temps on sait ou pas pour l'instant
on ne sait pas à mon avis ça va être au
moins un minimum un mois il est sous
surveillance qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ont peur voilà qui
est non seulement il est sur sous
surveillance puisque effectivement
beaucoup de gens ont peur qu'ils se
suicident et puis en plus il y a quand
même le parquet qui a fait appel de la
décision et donc on peut peut-être
imaginer ils ont 15 jours pour pour
répondre qu'il puisse être mis en
détention provisoire
Daniel non mais moi je trouve enfin je
lis beaucoup là les réseaux sociaux en
ce moment c'est vraiment un défairement
évidemment mais je trouve que le
scandale que dénonce les gens c'est
justement cette justice de vitesse parce
que c'est Pierre palan nous a expliqué
que c'est pas normal et en fait moi le
vrai fast Kim scandalise vraiment c'est
que on peut faire ce genre de choses et
la détention provisoire et quasiment
enfin c'est c'est pas la norme quoi donc
moi c'est ça qui me scandalise le plus
en fait il faudrait créer un délit
routier un vrai homicide routier ou
quelque chose pour voilà parce que là ça
nous satisfait pas pour l'instant mais
oui mais c'est important de dire quand
même 4h30 de débat entre de procureur
les avocats il y a l'aspect
psychologique a été quand même avancé
pendant pendant cette audition et puis
surtout le côté addictif qui n'aurait
peut-être pas permis une détention
provisoire immédiate alors pour
l'instant George il a été inculpé
domicile involontaire
oui reste à savoir si cet enfant a
respirer c'est ça s'il est né vivant
autrement il y a une jurisprudence à
court de cassation qui dit qu'il ne peut
pas y avoir domicile involontaire sur un
fœtus alors justement à quoi moi je vous
dis très franchement mon opinion ça me
choque profondément
j'ai eu instruire une affaire comme ça
ou un médecin s'était trompé de femme il
a enlevé soi-disant et stérilet en fait
il a percé la poche des eaux s'est
trompé de parturient et j'avais inculpé
à l'époque le médecin pour homicide
involontaire et je connaissais la
jurisprudence la Cour d'appel m'avait
suivi elle avait condamné le médecin et
puis la côte cassation a cassé et à
l'Assemblée nationale on avait porté un
texte pour reconnaître le missile à
volontaire sur un fœtus après tout le
fœtus fœtus il se citer un bébé vous
savez un bébé de 6 mois
c'est un bébé c'est pas un organe
moi je trouve ça choquant si vous voulez
qu'on ne puisse pas reprocher pas le cas
cette interruption involontaire je suis
d'accord bien sûr
terminer si l'enfant avait est sorti du
vent de sa mère avec en respiratoire
de mettre en examen pour homicide
involontaire et de faire changer la
jurisprudence pour la feuille revirement
jurisprudence
la question si je me pose l'ancienne on
va on va avoir Homer un neveu de l'une
des victimes de l'accident dans un
instant les autres victimes
aujourd'hui il y a cette affaire mais
ils sont mine de rien le préjudice il
est à vie pour eux aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que juridiquement
il y a rien qui se passe ça veut dire
c'est où on a commis un homicide ou bien
si on a voilà parce qu'il y a on a vu le
le petit de 6 ans il va être défiguré le
vie bien sûr
ça a été notifié par le procureur
aujourd'hui ce sont des séquelles
des rappels que l'assurance ne couvre
pas
ce genre d'accident sous l'emprise
ne couvre pas d'assurance va
effectivement couvrir les préjudices
adverses pas ceux de Pierre Palmade
adverse et va se retourner ensuite le
fond de garantie va se retourner ensuite
contre Pierre Palmade qui va payer toute
sa vie ça m'a coûté très cher et sa
famille c'est la moindre des choses ça
peut être sur éventuellement s'il
arrivait quelque chose sa famille les
ayant droits sont tenus de payer toute
leur vie aussi
c'est important
de soin mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
être surélement qui ne se redrode jamais
parce que ça va crainte aussi un
contrôle judiciaire avec des obligations
de soins
s'ils ne se soumet pas à cette
obligation il risque une incarcération
c'est une violation du contrôle
judiciaire et donc comment on le fait
c'est les médecins ça c'est les médecins
qui effectivement vont l'accompagner
dans sa rupture avec le produit
stupéfiant
alors on va voir il y a la concurrure de
Paris qui a été claire hier dans une
interview il y aura aucun traitement de
faveur pour Pierre Palmade et Homer
neveu de l'une des victimes de
l'accident qui les a vu aujourd'hui
viendra s'exprimer dans TPMP regardez il
sera jugé comme n'importe quel français
et d'ailleurs des opérations de contrôle
de produits stupéfiants s'effectue
régulièrement sur la plaque parisienne à
la sortie de soirée festive et donc il
n'y a absolument aucun traitement de
faveur au regard du produit utilisé ou
de la personnalité qui pourrait être
concernée par cet usage de produits
stupéfiants voilà on voit ce qu'a dit la
procureur de Paris ça a été clair bien
sûr voilà c'est un traitement faut
vraiment le dire et ça je le répète
parce que j'ai vu plein de choses
circuler sur les réseaux sociaux 0
traitement de faveur et j'enchaîne avec
viens nous le dire ça aurait été
exactement la même chose
pour tout le monde exactement voilà et
c'est vrai que je pense moi-même je
pense que c'est même plus un handicap en
vrai
avec toute la médiatisation je pense que
c'est plus un handicap et c'est très dur
mine de rien pour les magistrats aussi
de garder de ne pas voilà de ne pas être
voilà lancé par ce qui se dit exactement
ils ont fait comme pour quelqu'un
d'autre et je peux vous dire il y a pas
discuter là-dessus vraiment là il faut
faire confiance à la justice non mais
c'est vrai parce que sinon je vois plein
de choses à circuler sur les réseaux
voilà on vous le redit ils ont fait je
le fais en présence d'un membre de la
famille exactement